>>Presenter (Don Dodge): Thank you everyone
for coming. We have an all star panel of Venture
capitalists, the best in the business, hand
picked, they're all my friends. [laughter]
So I'm proud to say they're all my friends,
I’ve worked with them for many, many years.
So when Google said let’s do a panel, a
VC panel, I said I'm there, and we can bring
the right people here. Before we get started,
I've got a couple of questions for you. And
one announcement. Tonight there will be a
reception hosted by Google ventures. Ah, Joe
Kraus, is one of the partners, right here.
[clapping]. And David Crane over here from
Google Ventures. Ah you need a ticket like
this to get in. So if you want to come to
the Google Ventures reception see David Crane
or Joe Kraus or myself and we'll get you a
ticket to get in. Um, let me start with a
couple of questions. How many of you are from
Startups? Raise your hand. Alright, that warms
my heart.
Audience: [Google does not count as a startup]
>>Don: That's true. That's true. And how many
of you are either seeking funding, or will
soon be ready for your next round? Raise your
hand. OK, so keep your hands up. OK VC's those
are the guys you want to talk to. There's
about a Billion dollars of capital sitting
here. A Billion dollars. So you only want
50 Million, right? So, should be OK, should
be easy to do. there are Mic's over here in
the audience, so we want you to come up and
ask questions throughout. So I'll be watching
and recognizing you for questions, ok? I'm
gonna start with a few and then we'll take
your questions. But first let's start with
introductions in case you don't know these
guys. Let's have a minute or two introduction
for each of you. Let's start with Brad.
>>Brad: Brad Feld, I'm managing director of
a Venture firm in Boulder, Colorado called
Foundry Group. We do software Internet investing
all around the U.S. We're four partners, $225
million fund, 20 something companies that
we've invested in.
>>Dave: My name is Dave McClure. I paint houses
on the weekend for really low rates, so if
any of you guys need any work done, just let
me know.
[inaudible comment from audience]
>>Dave: [laughs] Um, I do earlier stage investing
that Brad I think. Probably if you're looking
for $20 checks, I’m your guy. I've done
about 40 or 50 investments over the last couple
of years with Founders Fund, running their
early stage program and the Facebook incubator
program last summer.
>>Jeff: [strong French accent] Um, Jeff Clavier,
he moved next to my house and so he's painting
it. Um, I'm at SoftTech VC which is a $15
million fund that has done 49 investments
in the past 2 years. And before that I did
24 as an Angel so I'm one of the most active
guys in the work pool space. And I'm thrilled
to be on the panel that doesn't talk about
the VC investment, but something else. Thank
you though.
>>Matt: Matt Holleran, Emergence Capital.
Emergence is a little different in that our
whole firm is focused on business applications
and particularly recurring revenue business
applications. In the Freemium market investments
include Yammer, and EchoSign and YouSendit.
And in the SAS world, ah companies like Salesforce.com
and SuccessFactors.
>>Joe: My name is Joe Kraus. I'm two time
entrepreneur. I started Excite in the early
'90's and a company called JotSpot about three
and a half years ago which I sold to Google.
And I recently joined the dark side. And ah,
of Google Ventures and I think we have 11
investments thus far, and we're a relatively
young shop, about a little over a year old.
>>Presenter: OK so this a panel about Freemium
and Free trial and revenue models for startups.
So to start maybe we should level set and
just have a brief explanation of Freemium,
Free trial and maybe open revenue models.
Does anyone wanna take that and just explain
what we mean by Freemium?
>>Jeff: So I'll give it a try. Um typically
you're gonna have an application with a set
of functionality which you're gonna make available
for free. And then a subset of those features
will be only available to people who pay a
bit of money because they have reached a point;
whether it's time, whether it's capacity,
whether it's storage, that you know, has max'd
out the free version. So you will say hey,
if you want to continue using our product,
or if you want the convenience of additional
features, you can pay us a certain monthly
fee. And typically there is a recurring model
where every month or every quarter whatever,
someone pays something.
>>Presenter: And what about Free trial? How
would you contrast Freemium to a Free Trial?
>>Joe: I just think the simple thing is the
free trial is typically the fully featured
product which you're allowed to use for a
limited period of time. And the Freemium model
always has a free component or always has
some functionality that's free and then you
can pay for additional features or capability
users etc.
>>Matt: I guess I'd take a slightly different
approach on it which is, in the business application
world, Freemium is a pretty revolutionary
new business model. And part of how it's different
is that business freemium applications are
bought. And historically business applications
have been sold and as Joe just described,
a free trial is inherently controlled by a
Sales person. A Freemium application that
you're using, you need permission to sell
to that end customer.
>>Don: So Freemium is sometimes not recognized
as a significant business model that you can
build a significant company from. But here
are a few examples of companies that I think
did pretty well. Skype. I think everyone knows
Skype. It's a multi billion dollar company
built on a freemium model. LinkedIn, Flicker,
Pandora, Ancestry, I think that, well Taipan,
DropBox; there's tons of them. The common
thread there, seems to be though that these
are consumer based applications. With millions
and millions of users. And my question is,
can enterprise apps also use Freemium? Can
it work? Do the economics work?
>>Dave: So I guess one thing that I might
point out as an example of that would be Twilio,
which isn't quite free, but the enterprise
version of Freemium is really fuckin' cheap.
Versus big SLA that cost me a lot of money.
>>Joe: It was only 2 minutes before you swore.
That's a land state record.
>>Dave: [laughs] It's my modus operandus to
get it out early so people aren't waiting
for it and then we can move on. So Twilio
has a relatively cheap cost structure. However
I think if you sort of want more enterprise
SLA agreements, then there's definitely more
you can pay for the product. And I think a
lot of, not necessarily consumer facing products,
but products that are for developer audiences
can be sold at the enterprise at the departmental
level at a relatively inexpensive cost. Typically
once the kind of corporation or enterprise
wants to start using it in a more regular
fashion or with some level of support, then
there might be an opportunity to sort of step
up to a larger cost structure. Not quite Freemium,
but maybe you know, Freemium-er.
>>Joe: Matt probably has the best data I assume,
given that he funds mostly enterprise SAS
models, but I personally think it's ah, a
little tough in that my data may be a little
bit old, but rule of thumb I always think
about is it's about a 2% [unintelligible]
conversion for most applications from Free
to Premium. At least that's what I've seen,
and seen in my own experience. The, ah, some
of the Anti-virus guys and some of the registry
cleaners get much higher than that. Upwards
of like, 11 to 15%. But most people aren't
registry cleaners and most people aren't Anti-virus
companies, so I think one of the tough parts
to the Freemium model is that when I talk
lots and lots of Freemium companies, the data
all seems to suggest that there's a , about
a 2%, not limit but at most on average, tend
to yield 2% when they're up and running and
humming.
>>Jeff: So I think the game for someone who
has a Freemium model in mind is to have a
massive funnel that they can drive people
through and eventually convert this into a
percentage. And that's why it sort of lends
itself naturally to the , the consumer market,
because you can have 10's of millions of users
and if you convert only 2% or 5% it's still
a lot of users.
>>Brad: You have some interesting historical
proxies for Freemium in the enterprise, and
the best one to use and then I'll map it to
Google specifically but the best one to use
is SharePoint which essentially has an incredibly
broad footprint in the enterprise, mostly
because for the first handful of years Microsoft
gave it away as part of the ELA agreement,
so you essentially got it if you bought the
ELA agreement; you got this extra functionality
for free. And then over time if you wanted
to have it broadly licensed there were opportunities
to then buy up the package. It's interesting
if you sort of make the metaphor to things
that cross over between consumer and enterprise,
you know Gmail and Google Apps seems like
a pretty natural example. Um, I can use Gmail
forever for free, and there is a clear opportunity
for me to then pay for Google Apps to start
to have certain things that I can't get if
I just have Gmail. So I think it's a little
subtle in it's difference because we're so
tuned in to the, these people that are building
consumer based products use. So tuned in to
give away a lot to convert 2%, to extra functionality
whether it's specific features or storage
etc. But I think the opposite is true in the
Enterprise which is give away something broadly
and get more distribution, as you build more
value on the product and get more people using
that product, then layer on a paid service.
So really it's the same model but as different
approach.
>>Don: I'd remind you there are microphones
in the audience. Just step up to the microphone
if you'd like to ask a question.
>>Dave: I just want to point out that there
are two or three different reasons why you
would offer something for free. One is because
you want to give the user time to understand
what the product is, and if you charge for
it right away, they may not take that time.
So that’s kind of learning about product
benefit. There's free because that user's
gonna provide distribution benefit and viral
fashion to other users. So I might tolerate
them being free forever as long as they're
inviting other users into the product. And
the third one is maybe close to that, but
you get network benefit by having more people
in. So you may tolerate them being a free-rider
as long as they're adding value in some way.
It may not be by invitation but by participation
of data. So I think understanding of why things,
why we're trying to get users in, and what,
you know what version of that will drive whether
it's free trial, or Freemium or Free forever,
or Free completely.
>>Matt: yeah and I think I guess our results
are, it's working in the business context
and the scale of the conversions are in the
kind of one to ten percent at limit that we're
starting to see. To Joe's point, you want
these markets to be really big. But two factors
connected to the virility right now are, really
no business application other than Intuit
historically has penetrated the ten employ
and less business. Gmail and Google Apps is
changing that. And the VSB market is many,
many tens of millions in the U.S and North
America. And these today out of the shoot,
these, the freemium business applications
companies are serving the globe. And so what
might not have been markets that worked in
a SAS context five years ago and certainly
didn't in a SAP Oracle context are now at
scale where that can work. And then to the
point on the difference between consumer and
business is I might love this thing and it's
a great service but now there's five people
or ten people like Chuck at SlideRock who
I just mentioned in the previous session,
you know, he gets now 5 or 10 people from
Google Apps off the market place that see
the solution versus one. And you can start
to seed applications and then sell them a
more expensive product later, that change
the economics pretty significantly in the
business. I guess the model is really going
after new segments and new opportunities today
that are of scale, that can really make the
economics work and it's really exciting.
>>Don: Brad did you have a comment?
>>Brad: Yeah I think one thing to also be
aware of, I'd just add a fourth thing to Dave's
list, and do I get a card if I say Fuck too
early on? OK just checking. So there's a lot
of people they get confused about direct versus
indirect revenue models as well in the context
of Freedium, ah Freemium and I’ll give a
good example from my experience. I was an
investor in FeedBurner, and FeedBurner had
a free version and then they had a $5 a month
version that you got a bunch of extra stuff;
you got analytics and a few other things.
And when Google bought the company we had
500,000 publishers using FeedBur, ah, ah FeedBurner.
And of those 500,000 customers we had 2,000
of 'em that paid us $5 a month. So our $10,000
a month revenue stream was worthless in the
freemium model. However by having 500,000
publishers, we were aggregating 100's of millions
of unique ad impressions a day through all
of the distributions that we had and our indirect
model because advertising through those impressions.
And so I think one thing that a lot of companies
get side swiped in that we see early on is
that they have this notion of Freemium where
it's just systematically built. I mean I don’t
think that FeedBurner guys thought that they'd
only have 2,000 people paying for all the
extra happy stuff. The very first thing that
Google did was make those 2,000 users free
and gave those functionality across everybody
because they recognized that the value of
the incremental unique ad unit was much higher.
So sort of in a counter freemium model don't
get hung up in losing sight of the fact that
you might have a better indirect revenue opportunity
than direct and always challenge your free
to paid user versus what if it was all free?
Do we have an indirect model? There's an interesting
backlash that Freemium came from, for anybody
that sort of remembers the web tour history,
was that there were this enormous number of
companies that were gonna make it up on volume,
right? They were gonna have huge enough traffic
that they were gonna have a big enough advertising
revenue stream. And at some point everybody
realized that you know, when you have 10,000
unique users a day you can’t have enough
advertising to make a business. You gotta
figure out a different way to do it. So one
of the things to think about when you're starting
down the path of a Freemium model, is are
you a company who's gonna have 10's of thousands
of, or 100's of thousands of users? Or are
you a company that's gonna have 50 Million
users? And if you're gonna have 50 million
users and you can leverage the network effect
type activity that Dave talked about, the
Freemium model may actually get in your way
relative to the indirect opportunities that
you have for advertising.
>>Dave: And in fact that often times the big
issue in freemium is not whether to do Freemium
but what’s the product feature segmentation
on the free versus the paid side. And how
do you sort of, like you know, which features
are we gonna put on the paid side and which
features are we gonna put on the free side.
In general things that are viral or growth
oriented probably shouldn't be on the paid
side, they should be on the free side. Ah
and you know, maybe stuff that sort of engages
users in more deep behavior is probably stuff
that you may want to consider putting on the
paid side.
>>Joe: I'd think there's real danger in the
Freemium model which is it creates a weird
cultural split inside your company. I saw
this at JotSpot where you're constantly having
discussions about, what are we, so Dave's
point, what do we include in the free version,
what do we include in the paid version? And
ah, your company can get a little, of kind
of a split personality with some people pushing
for holding things back and some people pushing
for greater growth and it's really hard to
know what that line is. And the line evolves
over time. I think the second really important
thing is pricing. And how you do pricing.
So one of the lessons we learnt at JotSpot,
we studied cell phone pricing a lot. If you
look at Cell phone pricing, people, ah people,
if you look at large cohorts, pay one greater
tier than they should. And why do they do
that? Coz actually the rational thing to do
is pay one lower tier and the 2 months a year
you go over, you just pay the overage. you'll
actually net a lower bill at the end of the
year. The reason people do it, is they’re
not optimizing for lowest price, they're optimizing
for least surprise. And so one of the things
we did when we looked at our tiers of pricing
at JotSpot was, how do we create a tier, like
the initial two tiers let's say at $19.95
a month and $29.95 a month, had limits on
things like users and pages. If you went up
to $49.99 cents a month then you essentially
got one of those categories became unlimited.
And what we saw is our average revenue per
user which we tracked weekly as we adjusted
pricing plans was that people still, even
in software, optimized towards least surprise.
They didn't know how they were gonna use this
stuff, as long as it was in the range of cheap
enough then they'd optimize to least surprise
and basically take the higher plan even if
they don't use it. So we saw people taking
plans which were essentially had an unlimited
pages component and were using by far fewer
pages than they could have at the next price
level down. But they did it because they were
pricing for least surprise.
>>Presenter: Interesting. Very Interesting.
So that's a good Segway into my next
>>xxx: [talks over presenter] Super awesome,
like feedback. The point that I wanted to
make though about the other thing you said
was you think it develops a split personality.
I actually think that's Okay. because I think
there's, you know, there's two things you
wanna optimize for when you're running these
businesses. One is you're trying to optimize
for user happiness or utility. The other one
is you're trying to optimize for business
value. And sometimes you're playing a zero
sum game with that. Hopefully not always.
[laughs]. And great businesses are where you're
not playing zero sum games with those two
things. but I think its actually OK to have
a customer advocate in your company who's
always trying to like figure out what’s
gonna make the comp, customer the most happy.
And somebody else is hey we have to keep the
lights on, how do we make the most value in
the business. And having that you know, that
dichotomy of conversation on an ongoing basis
is probably ok in my opinion.
>>Joe: I'll revise the statement. What's actually
important is that you start from the beginning
with the model you imagine yourself to have.
Meaning, too many companies when they start
up, basically put their product in Beta before
putting their business model in beta. So what
they do is they typically release a free product,
they don't have any pricing on the thing,
and they start to get a bunch of users, and
the users get excited. They have a fully featured
product. And then the conversation starts
to go like this; you have 10,000 users, 20,000
users and you start to get nervous. Well gosh,
if we introduce a pay wall, how is that gonna
change our growth? And boy we seem to be valued
and get all the love and feedback inside the
company and these people from the outside
who might fund us, love us because we seem
to be on this user ramp, so all I’m saying
is, at the very beginning, make a decision
and put your business model into beta at the
same time you put your initial product into
beta. And that way you don't have the tough
conversations being really nervous that you're
gonna retard growth ramps that aren't really
real.
>>Brad: I'd also add knowing that, and I agree
with Joe's sort of approximate 2% conversion,
maybe it's a little more, there's a coupla
cases where it spikes up a little higher but
it's a low percentage. I think that if you
try to implement or sort of over architect
it too early, you also don't understand what
you're doing. Because let's say that you said
that we're going to have a Premium model,
we're going to have some extra features, you
get some user adoption and you put out your
freemium model. This is the free one. This
is the $14.95 a month, versus 15 a month because
someone told you, you should be $14.95 a month.
And um, you got the wrong segmentation. If
you don't have tension early around what that
segmentation is, you'll stick and anchor on
that segmentation and you'll slow your user
growth down. SO what I tend to see works is,
you know you're gonna introduce a pay wall
at some point, but you wait until you have
enough robustness in the product before you
start to do that segmentation. And you play
around with that segmentation. And I think
the dissonance in the company in that case
is super helpful. Coz then you'll have people
in the company fighting for the user; this
has to be a core feature, it can't be a paid
feature, and then you'll have somebody else
make the argument yeah but this is why people
are going to pay for us. And you have to get
that conversation going in the companies,
and FeedBurner was an example, oh yeah we'll
just add stats on and people will pay us extra
for stats, and the answer was no they won't.
And oh by the way if we'd had Stats for free
we probably would've had more adoption coz
there would've been some people who would've
said ah we'll get some extra benefits from
this.
>>Jeff: I think FeedBurner was a good example
of a product where it was so good on the free
side that there was absolutely no reason for
you to take the paid one. It's only when they
introduced the notion of advertising where
you would get paid for impressions that I
felt compelled to pay them something because
I felt guilty. So introduce guilt.
>>Brad: that's interesting coz they didn't
need you to feel guilty because they took
a percentage of the advertising revenue, right?
So they didn't care. The interesting thing
was they had competitors who charged for their
functionality. They actually got the right
mix I think of lots of functionality for free
because the people that charged a relatively
small amount for the other functionality ended
up with like 17 people using their product
and FeedBurner ended up with half a million.
So that’s the other side of the equation,
which is that if you're going after scale
you have to really concentrate on where you're
segmenting to go after scale. I think that
is part of the problem then with the enterprise
type activities coz if you're selling into
an enterprise customer, now lets not talk
about the very small business, but sort of
anything else, you're still dealing with an
Oracle sales force, you're still dealing with
a Microsoft sales force, you're still fighting
against SAS, so you've gotta figure out a
different approach into the customer still
on top of a different engagement model.
>>Don: So if the free product is so good that
there's no reason to pay, then you’re only
alternative then is to say well we'll limit
capacity. Right? So you can only do a hundred
a month or a thousand a month, or whatever
the scale is, so. That's really the tough
problem. Where do you draw the line? Do you
draw the line to say we're going to hold back
certain features and make those the Premium
that you pay for? Or we're gonna give them
but limit capacity and have them pay if they
go over capacity. So how have you seen that
work and what are your recommendations?
>>Jeff: It really depends on the product.
I think that if there is a notion of quota
of capacity, I think DropBox is a great example.
I'm not involved in Dropbox but I think it's
an awesome product. So you get 2GB for free
and you can pay for like, whatever, 10 or
something like that. And I think that in between
there is a very large band of users who will
sort of, try and force themselves to stay
in the 2, because 2GB is pretty large for
Web Storage. But what Drew said, the CEO,
is that if they were to lower that ball to
try and introduce an interim sort of step
they would actually lose money because people,
just as Joe said, just graduating to the 10GB
offer just for safety. And so when you have
those kinds of products you can definitely
sort of play on storage capacity limitations.
I think that the whole limitation on product
is dangerous because there's always sort of
something you want the users to experience
to make sure you maintain a competitive edge.
>>Matt: I think the other opportunity there
is as you're starting on your journey, is
you need to be clear on the runway. And useful
functionality for an individual for the discussion,
and set that mark at something that they delight
in, and they're really happy about but hopefully
have some more to drive some individual conversion.
On the business apps side though, is you know,
you could really have a very useful individual
product and your goal very well could be,
I'm gonna up sell the group. And that can
work beautifully. And so, but if you don't
have enough runway individually, and you don't
really have group value in the enterprise,
it may not be something you want to embark
on.
>>Don: We have a question from the audience
here. Let's take that one.
>>Audience Male 1: [Strong middle eastern
accent] I want to know individually which
characteristics does a good business has,
have for each one of you?
>>Don: What characteristics would a business
have for this?
>>Audience Male 1: Yes. What business, which
characteristics for a good business have in,
have? It's a question for each one of you.
>>Don: Oh, so does it have to be viral, does
it have to be consumer, or what kind of characteristics
do you look for? Is that the question?
>>Dave: I think it's
>>Audience Male 1: I will, well, I would like
to hear more about the values of, now we have
to protect our investors, now we have to be
true our, these characteristics of the product,
or we have to be true our self or?
>>Dave: I think I guess I would say, well
the awesome product of course is the real
time viral croupon. I mean like that's obviously
going to get everybody to get their check
books out. Um, but I think one of the things
we've been sort of talking about is getting
to the essence of what's the value to the
user. And
>>Brad: Virtual goods.
>>Dave: Right, right. Virtual goods. Um coz
I was going to say Joe's comment about not
shipping your product without putting your
business model into beta is pretty on target.
But um, getting to the sort of, reverse psychology
in this, I don't know how many of you have
read Predictably Irrational? but I think that's
a great book to read before you start trying
to think about, uh, any type of Freemium model
because some of your intuitions about how
people are going to react to pricing are very,
very different. In particular I think there
are times when you can charge for something
that people perceive more value than when
you give it away. So the behavioral aspects
of sort of having something free or not free
are not gonna at all look like what your expectations
are there. So, in fact founder of a company
in Japan, the largest cooking site in Japan,
Cookpad, founder Aki Sano built a business
over about 12 or 13 years. they went public
last year doing very, very well. He actually
thinks completely different about it in that
he doesn’t want a launch anything that people
wouldn’t pay for right out of the gate.
because it sort of sets a way that users think
about your product to be value oriented. And
I'm not saying that works for everybody but
really establishing , you know, the value
of your product is probably more important
than understanding pricing models right away.
So getting to the essence of your product
is probably the first priority and then figuring
out how do you layer on pricing that’s either
free or discounted on top of that.
>>Don: Brad mentioned virtual goods. And I
know brad is an investor in Zynga which makes
a ton of money on virtual goods.
[inaudible comment from Dave]
>>Don: [laughs] Well it was in that case
>>Brad: Well I mentioned virtual goods just
to be part of the trend of word dropping.
Um Dave's point is profound, I want to emphasis
it, actually
>>Dave: I agree with you, my point was profound.
>>Brad: It's fucking profound. [laughs] Um,
it's really, really important, your instinct
about what the consumer, or sorry, what your
customer, business or consumer will pay for
or not pay for, is likely wrong. It's very
easy to come out with a model after you've
read some blogs and talked to some people
and thought in the bathroom about something.
And it's probably going to be wrong. So you
have to be agile and flexible enough early
in the life curve of your business if you're
going to approach this model. To be able to
listen to your customer feedback, your user
feedback . And also have the right premise.
If you're premise around your business is
that you have to have 100 million people using
your thing, and your thing is not viral in
any way shape or form, it will not work. If
your premise is that you only need 10,000
people to pay you $1000 a month and life is
good, Free may not be your path. Or the thing
that you do for free may be different. So
testing it aggressively and iterating is important,
but hanging on to Dave's concept that your
intuition is probably not right. The other
thing I just want to weigh in, which Don said
is what if your free product is so good that
you know, the free version is all anybody
will ever need? And that assumes stasis, assumes
that nothing changes. And everything’s changing
constantly and evolving constantly and I think
that’s another opportunity where once you
start to have enough users finding the one
or two percent of users who are fanatical
about your product and having them help you
segment where the pay wall should be is actually
quite useful.
>>Dave: I think an interesting case of that
is LinkedIn. So I mean LinkedIn is a clear
case of products free, I don't know why I
would ever pay for what they currently are
charging the users for in their freemium model.
And they monetize generally on, really a special
segment of users which is BizDev and recruiters
and other things. Now I don't know whether
that's right or not, I actually think there's
potentially a chance they should have charged
for the business premium users coz I sure
as hell would pay $20-$50 a month for the
value that I get out of LinkedIn. But they
chose this model where OK we're gonna give
the user a bunch of benefit with really not
too much limitations on functionality and
monetize a completely different user segment
that will pay coz there's large network effects
going on.
>>Brad: There's large value from the people
that will pay disproportionately high for
the other 98%, or whatever the percent is
that won't pay anything at all. Right? So
you might pay $50 a month for it, but somebody
else will pay $500 or $1000 bucks a month
for it or $5000 and so they need a whole lot
less people paying to make the same aggregate
revenue. So again, there's so many pieces
in it that's sort of looking for that right
spot that actually I think having a competence
or, this is you know, back to Joe's point
about you know, you have two parts to the
company once you start sort of rolling down
that path, figure out how to let that dissonance
be part of your decision making process in
a constructive way, I think is really powerful.
>>Don: Ok we have another question from the
audience.
>>Audience Male 2: [Japanese accent] Hello,
my name is Yohalven from Taipei. I have one
comment and one question. The first comment
is that you mentioned many different models
of revenue and it feels to me as if Freemium
is mostly when dealing with direct consumer
when we're talking about giving them away,
the product for free, when we can get moneys
in other ways like advertisement that was
mentioned here, and information collection.
So I wonder about the balance between those
different models. And the second thing is
that you mentioned Zynga a few minutes ago.
And Zynga have a different model, Zynga give
the product completely for free. And they
ask their consumer to pay by enabling features,
by paying for them every time. You actually
buy coins, you buy virtual currency, you pay
for specific features. After a while you have
to buy those again. So it's another, it seems
like another model of Freemium and I would
be happy to hear your comments about it.
>>Joe: So ah, obviously Brad knows most about
Zynga, but I've spent a bunch of time looking
in kind of mobile gaming space where economics
are slightly different but the mechanisms
are the same. And I'll compare it to a bunch
of stuff that comes out of, um, Neil Young
from NGMoko talked a lot about his metrics
at the Game Developers Conference a while
ago. So what’s interesting about their metrics
is that on a daily basis they see that 2%
of their audience are buying something with
virtual goods. Now one of the most important
parts in that model is that they're a legitimate
play path and a legitimate pay path. And that
balance is really important. I don’t know
what the analogue in Business software would
be personally, but that 2% kind of scales
well to other data points that I was mentioning
earlier about 2%. The more interesting part
to me is that ah, about 25% of their audience
will do something in exchange for the paid
currency, typically in the mobile case in,
cost per install advertising, um and so in
that particular case as you mentioned the
balancing act. And then a third component
is essentially display advertising. But all
of that adds up in to the magnitude of 15
cents a daily active user per day. So it's
a amazing how collecting pennies over enough
users where you combining Freemium where you're
actually getting revenue directly from customer
base. But where that again seems to be tapping
out at about 2%. Where you have other people
willing to get value in the game in exchange
for doing some other action that you can monetize.
This is kind of akin to what Brad was talking
about in terms of indirect monetization with
advertising in the case of FeedBurner and
then obviously advertising, so. Anyway that's
just another example of another revenue mix
that might be interesting.
>>Don: You've mentioned the 2% conversion
rate a couple of times. I did a survey of
25 companies that are using Freemium model.
And it was very close, but my results were
between 3% and 5% depending on the price point
that they were charging. Lower price point
got 5% conversion, the lower price, 3%. So
if your business models have rates of 10%
or 20% you're smoking something, it's not
right. Its gonna be between 2 and 5%
>>Joe: On this point I think there's 2 kind
of follow-on’s I wanna make. One is that
entrepreneurs live in a reality distortion
field, I've been there many times. I love
my little bubble. But the reality is that
most people don't know what you're talking
about with your product. And so there was
an earlier question about should you charge
for holding back features. The reality is
most people are not going to pay you for your
features. You think your features are incredibly
valuable. yeah but you spend 24/7 thinking
about your product and understanding what
the value of those features are. It is likely
not gonna happen. I very much personally prefer
the notion of being aligned with your customer.
The more they use the product the more they're
seeing value the deeper they’re getting
in it, then they're willing to pay something.
That’s at least my own impression. You need
to hold some carrots out there or some words
that make people feel like they're getting
a little more value than just additional stuff
for what they're already using. But again
I strongly prefer things that are aligned
with the way the customers using the product.
And avoid the trap of thinking that customers
are gonna pay for features, they won't . Customers
don't pay typically for analytics. they don't
pay to turn ads off. they don't pay for, at
least in the enterprise case they will, but
in the consumer case they're not gonna pay
for better support for the most part. Um,
so, that's one. Two is, always remember, at
least in, again and this is my own personal
opinion, it's much easier to raise prices
than to lower prices. So I always like starting
with lower price points and creeping them
up very aggressively and measuring on a weekly
basis what I'm seeing in terms of average
revenue for account. The reason its easier
to raise prices than to lower prices? The
people who got the earlier price feel like
they got a smoking deal. When you lower prices,
they're very pissed off. So it's counter intuitive,
people are afraid to raise prices. Raise prices,
it's not hard compared to lowering prices.
>>Jeff: A couple of comments. One is um, on
the 2-5%, it depends whether you look at your
overall user base or your active users. Coz
typically you're going to try and focus on
your active users in terms of conversions.
So you’re gonna see a much higher conversion
rate by definition coz your active users is
a lower population. In terms of the consumer,
people actually pay for convenience. Um, one
of my companies did something that you shouldn't
do, which is they actually took something
which was available for free and they made
it only available behind the pay wall. And
there was a pure revolution amongst the user
base. But you know, after a year we ended
up with a 4 person, 4 percent conversion rate,
we were making millions of dollars on that
4%. And we just went past the renewals, so
after a year we were very anxious looking
at the turn we'd have on this sort of year,
after a year of activity. And so far we've
seen 70% of people sort of renewing. So I'm
not suggesting to piss off your users. But
be aware that at some point if you have a
product that is really sticky and people want
to use, and that's convenient, and they will
actually pay.
>>Matt: I think this brings up a point about
instrumentation and really knowing usage.
and so It drives on two things. One, the active
user retention is something that generally
SAS companies aren't thinking about because
they're only talking about paid user retention.
But thinking about active user retention,
instrumenting the service, really knowing
the clicks and streams and functionality that
people are using and how to engage them, is
a really, really big point. Not only for you
getting them to convert but for them to go
tell their friends. And this brings up a big
difference between what I'll call kind of
early recurring revenue model businesses and
kind of early SAS and these in that these
are really service businesses at the end of
the day. I mean people, in fact in many of
these companies 40-60% of the employees are
in technical support and customer service
and they think that's great. because they’re
really worried about active users, telling
their friends and then driving conversion
and then doing the work to make sure all that
all of those things happen. Contrast that
with kind of historical on the business apps
side where 50 or 60% of the folks were selling,
in this case it's 40 or 60% are services and
it really speaks to some of the cultural differences
between these entities and those that came
before.
>>Brad: One comment on Analytics and then
one comment on sort of the context of Freemium
at the infrastructure layer in terms of the
infrastructure service which we haven't really
touched on, that I think is becoming increasingly
visible. Raise your hand if you have a company,
an active company today. Keep your hands up.
Lower your hand if you don't get a detailed
statistics report everyday on daily active
users and what they're doing in the application?
Be honest. [laughter] Okay. 25-33%. 100% of
you should be obsessed with that. And every
company at the very earliest stages, even
if you have four people using your software,
you have somewhere between 5 and 10 daily
metrics that you should get every day and
you should think about and then think about
them on a weekly basis and a monthly basis.
And Dave's got brilliant stuff on SlideShare
about this. And on his site, no, not about
the actual metrics you should look at. but
understanding those metrics and understanding
the difference between a daily active user,
a weekly and a monthly active user , understanding
what they're doing in the application, and
understanding how that changes over time especially
when you change the application. It's so critical
early on and so many startups I encounter
have no idea what it is. I love the reports
that say you know, have a handful of columns
on a daily basis, you know 7,7,8,8,14 because
that day it went from 8 to 14 you can say
well what happened there? Like what was it?
And very early understanding those nuances
will help you understand the dynamics here,
but don't, sort of defaulting into the 2%
Jeff’s point of, is it daily users? Is it
sign ups? Then shift into the infrastructure
thing, you're seeing more and more companies
like this. We just made an investment yesterday
in a company in Boulder called Simple GO,
and we have another investment that should
close by the end of the month that has exactly
the same type of approach where it's a free
infrastructure service for certain number
of, for a certain amount of usage, a certain
number of API calls, a certain volume of activity
you can use this service for free and integrate
into your service. Once you get above some
level then you have some tier pricing based
on your consumption. So if there, SendGrid
would be another one that we're all in that
we recently let around and that Jeff and Dave
are also in. It's one of those things where
the infrastructure piece of it, you, this
is a business service, you want lots of people
to try it and you're willing to have that,
that marginal cost on your side because it's
cloud based, it's cloud deployed, your marginal
cost is relatively low. When there's user
value, user's will happily pay your paid service
once you get above that hurdle. So it's again
the same kind of thing. If you have a thousand
people sign up and zero use it pass that sign
up period, nobody's gonna pay you $5000 a
month for it. If you’re not tracking it
you have no idea, and you could be telling
yourself oh yeah we got lots of people signing
up every day, why aren't we getting anybody
to convert into actual real users. So getting
those pieces lined up is really important.
>>Don: Great advice. Write that down. if you
aren't collecting analytics on how your users
are using your application, you're flying
blind. And if you succeed its gonna be total
luck. So make sure you do that.
>>Dave: On that point, the other thing I was
going to say is looking at a sort of unsubscribe
report or at least a cohort analysis for retention
over time. Like I think a lot of times understanding
what your balance is gonna be on a Freemium
model or how much you wanna charge for your
product whether it's free or not, is based
on an average customer lifecycle. And like,
a lot of people do look at daily reports or
look at aggregated stats where users are of
a different age, and you may not be able to
tell as much from that, unless you're looking
at the cohort that's just new user behavior
within a certain time period. So like an interesting
report that’s probably a pain the ass to
generate but useful to look at is kind of
a look back from current time frame of users
in the same week, or users in the same month.
So here's a cohort of users from 3 months
back, whets their behavior been? Ok here is
the next one week you know, cohort, we changed
something then what happened to the subscribe
rates or unsubscribe rates. And so getting
an understanding of what’s your average
customer like, retention over a billing period,
and starting to build some understanding of
customer acquisition cost and then figuring
out if you're upside down or not on that is
probably essential to understanding if you
have a business.
>>Don: We have two questions from the audience.
Lets go there.
>>Audience Male 2: Hi there, my name is Mike
I'm from Winnipeg, Canada and I have a privately
funded small startup that we're doing a booking
application. And we have sort of a big vision
to sort of take it to a one stop, ah, appointment
booking shop for common services which kind
of isn't out there from what I've seen. And
so one of the things we're trying to do, and
now, and what I wanted to ask you is basically
we're trying to figure out our pricing model
and potentially some sort of a freemium model
and trying to figure out whether a pay as
you go pricing, and in our scenario it could
work coz we're trying to sell initially a
web application that lets businesses schedule
appointments essentially. So its not new,
there's already companies doing this but we
just think we can do it better. Now traditionally
most, most, most of our competitors are pricing
on a tiered pricing model. Um, I'm really
wondering if a pay as you go model is better
in that you know, for a small shop that's
only booking a few appointments, why are they
going to pay $20 a month right? Where they
can pay a few cents per appointment, kind
of thing. And then how does that fit in with
the freemium model and how would you transition
that?
>>Don: A crowded market. I know. I saw Yori
Nelken here early from Timebridge, Tungle,
so there's a bunch of companies in there trying
to do this, and they all have slightly different
business models.
>>Joe: I'm only scared of pay as you go models
mainly because they’re unpredictable and
people get scared of what they don't know.
So the fact is they might think, it's interesting
people tend to go towards what if I did a
thousand appointments this month strangely,
I don't think I will but what if that happened?
So I tend not to, I tend not to like those
as much mainly coz what you're really are
looking for is you don’t want customers
to have to think very hard. And they have
to think when it's a pay as you go model coz
then they have to stop and think well how
many appointments do I really book coz most
people don't actually know. It would be my
instincts, but that's why I tend not to favor
those.
>>Matt: I think it's also, you have to be
careful on the bond math, in all of this and
you have to be clear as Dave explained earlier
in the customer lifecycle, and so your cost
to get a free user, your cost to get a paid
user and then how much are they gonna pay
you? If they pay you up front for a year,
they basically have recouped the cost of marketing
to them. And then what's the monthly retention
look like on GoForward, coz you're effectively,
you'll be financing their pay as you go. And
if that bond math all works, that's all free
coming in to you , they all love your service,
and 99% of them will stay, and you're winning
coz its pay per use, that bond math might
work, but you have to run that bond math all
the way through. And in these businesses in
particular coz we're talking about retention,
these are very different business application
retention rates than SAS or other services.
They're one to ten to 15% churn per month.
If you 15% churn per month, at the end of
the year you don't have a lot left, right?
So but people think about those differently
coz people move in and they move out and they’ll
do it for 3 months and they'll come back and
how do you think about, you know, that math?
So I guess all it really comes down to what's
the bond math really look like for your full
customer lifecycle for paid, and if that works
and enable you to differentiate, then that
may work except for the, kind of the fear
questions that Joe surfaced. But you wanna
run it all the way through.
>>Don: Let's get another question.
>>Audience Male 3: Hi. Ah, you guys talk a
lot about the subscription model where user
pays month after month, ah what do you think
of the model that seems to be in the mobile
space quite a bit where there's like App Lite,
then theirs Full App and the App Lite is free
and then the user jumps over the wall once
and pays a large bulk of money to get the
full featured app?
>>Jeff: That's been very popular as a model
on the apps tour because that was the only
way for companies to have a Premium model.
Where there was not the In App [unintelligible]
in existence. And so the math typically would
lead to a, surprise, surprise, 2-4% conversion
where the price point, so at Apputers' which
is one of the largest App on the App store,
we sort of did a demand curve to try and see
what the optimal pricing was. And essentially,
once again surprise, surprise, you know $4.99
seemed to be optimal. Now that you have an
opportunity to charge in App, you really want
to do your math because essentially if you're
able to get consumers to buy things on a repeated
basis, you know, $1.99 two track song, or
you know whatever sells on, um, on some first
person tutor, you will have a recurring revenue
of sorts that will make you way more than
that $4.99 and so.
>>Brad: I think it sucks and I think as a
function of a limitation of the app store,
sort of the first wave of it and here's why.
We're talking now about bits not atoms, right?
So bits cost us nothing. The storage cost
to them is nothing, the distribution cost
to them is nothing from a manufacture perspective.
So you'd never want a customer to be a single
purchase, or single instance experience because
all of your effort is to get engagement with
that customer. And if they have a single instance
experience to pay you for something, whether
it's $1.99, $4.99, $4,000 for your bits and
you don't have another way to keep doing it,
all that effort to get that customer to write
that check the first time, go back to Joe's
point earlier, psychologically, or philosophically
don't make people think hard. I love this
thing you do, I want more of it, oh it costs
me more money, Ok here's more money. But if
I can't ever give you more money, I won't.
Right? So I think you know Jeff's point was
exactly right, but I'll just put a point on
it, was it was a constraint, not a feature.
And it's something that I think will always
exist. I mean you can still buy PC software
and pay $29 bucks one time for it. And once
you've paid your 29 bucks, it's not like the
new version comes out, you want the new version
for free or for whatever your upgrade price
is, but you're not gonna pay anything more
than $2.99 for your annual maintenance agreement
because you're only willing to pay 10% of
it. right, it's just, its a tough place relative
to the fact that the storage shipping distribution
costs of this thing is zero. Sorry I didn't
mean to grab it.
>>Jeff: You did. [laughs]. Um, I agree with
Brad, I would just say that once again, once
you have enough distribution you have enough
freedom to do a bunch of different things
in terms of spatial versions and, and that’s
a recurring visual GUI or whatever you sell.
And essentially the goal is to increase the
[unintelligible] of the customer. And as long
as you create things that they want to buy
through different channels then you're off
to a good start. But I would just say that
the one time hey, I sold my app for like five
bucks and that's it. It's just not an attractive
model at all.
>>Don: Ok, we only have a few minutes left,
so we're going to go to the lightening round
now. Short questions, and 30 second answers.
Next question
>>Audience Male 5: Ah, You all talk about
>>Don: Speak up. We can't hear you.
>> Audience Male 5: Yes. You talk about having
a business plan before you start. But you
also talk about how your always wrong, or
your often wrong, how do you make sure that
you are not stuck in the bubble where a better
business plan , sorry, could be available
but you just don't see it because you're in
a bubble?
>>Don: Analytics
>>Joe: Yeah, I was just going to basically
say, the HP famous phrase is you make what
you measure. And so my only piece of advice
on that particular front is, and I've screwed
this up twice, is get your analytics in place
before you launch that product. Invariably
in every product discussion before launch
that I've ever had inside a company is always,
it's the last thing, it's not done, but we're
at some event so we're going to launch the
product on that particular day. We can't get
our dashboards done, we'll do it the week
after the launch, and it happens 5 months
later because you're incredibly busy.
>>Jeff: And in order to discover things
[audience member off Mic comments]
>>Joe: The point was start logging the data
before you can even analyze it. That's right.
>>Jeff: And you try new things on a sub-portion
of your user base. You do split testing, you
try things, like special [unintelligible]
or whatever. If you want to change the business
model, obviously you don't want to change
the entire thing. But if you have a hunch
based on your usage data, that there is another
opportunity, then you try your opportunity
on just a cohort or something.
>>Don: Next question. We got to go.
>>Audience Male 6: Just clarifying. Testing
and integration is great for local Macs optimization,
it's not necessarily as great for non-local
Macs discovery, so I still think you have
to create a process. And when your conversion
starts decelerating on your process for local
Macs optimization, that's the time to then
jump to a non intuitive leap for a new feature,
and potentially a new business model.
>>Don: OK, next question
>>Audience Male 7: For small and medium businesses,
is the lack of advertising, in your opinion,
enough of a feature to get money out of them?
And where does advertising in freemium play?
>>Don: Hi Bob, good to see you.
>>Matt: I think it was addressed earlier in
the sense that you have to think that you
have scale. I think the only real free medium
models which are working with advertising
right now and business applications, are Google
Apps, which is working well in a mixed mode
of subscription and advertising, and LinkedIn
as described, and they have scale of 7 to
a 100 million users. Cos advertisers don't
really care for some of the volumes that people
start to see. But if you're starting to think
about, how can you get leverage in these things
early, because it can take a while for virility
to happen. I will encourage you to think hard
about the Google market place and Google App
integration. Because companies like BatchBlue
are growing their customer base by 100% more
than they were doing before, and their retention
rates will be a lot higher, or Manymoon as
you might have just heard. So you can do this
by your own and run for a long time on your
own or you can stand on the shoulders of giants
like Google and others and really leverage
a freemium base globally to get your business
cranking.
>>Brad: I also think a very small percentage
of people would pay to not have ads. And if
your ads are so offensive that they will pay
to not have ads, they're not going to use
your service. So you have sort of a really
tough balance right there.
>>Don: Next question?
>>Audience Male 5: If your application is
targeting high net worth individuals for example
or a client base that has a lot of money,
is it wise to just try to, you know, I know
you mentioned earlier it's best to raise prices
rather than try to lower them, but like at
what point do you like you know, hey this
is actually a good price and value for my
clients but clear up here is where they pay.
I mean how far do push that bar?
>>Dave / Don: [in unison] As far as you can
before they stop paying.
[audience laughter]
>>Don: As far as you can
>>Dave: So that math should be relative to
competitively available alternatives, so if
there's no competitively available alternatives,
charge through the fucking nose. Um, [laughs]
and by the way don't worry about making it
perfect before you launch either. If there’s
lots of competitive alternatives you have
to do the math of available pricing, whether
the audience is aware of those other alternatives,
etc.
>>Audience Male 5: Cool, thanks guys.
>>Don: Next.
>>Audience Male 6: [Latin American Accent]
Yeah. Um, the applications we're developing
we want to try out in the Latin American market
and that tends to be all complicated because
it has some new challenges, it poses some
new challenges. People are not as used to
other current payments as you guys are up
here. So the conversion rates may be a little
lower. But also we have a problem with lack
of Bankerization, I don't know if that is
the appropriate word but not as many people
have actual credit cards that they can use
in the United States. For example the Venezuelan
users they have currency control, they cannot
use a credit card up here. So you have to
look into alternate methods of payments like
for example SMS Micro payments and what not.
What has been your experience in using Freemium
models for them? Is it better to try and force
some kind of monthly payment for them or go
and use a sort of virtual currency method
where you buy credits and you use your credits
as you go. I know we've touched on Pay as
you go method, but we have new challenges
here.
>>Jeff: So you want to try and shoot for frictionless
payment. So if there is a ton of friction
in you patch of , you know geography, I think
that the credit model can work because you
can just load up once your credit and then
consume them. The good news is that you can
therefore disconnect the act of payment and
the act of consumption. But you know, we're
used to have people who can bank, so we're
sort of less used to those kinds of models.
>>Matt: Billing and management of subscriptions
is an enormous business opportunity and problem
for you in this mode. And internationally
in particular, in some cases people are substituting
labor for the payment and it's fine because
it'll tell people who may have the ability
to pay so I wouldn’t be as concerned about
that. Google payments, as they've just announced
will be part of both Marketplace and how and
where you can get paid from your own customers.
And other suggestions for you, I mean PayPal
now has operations in, you know, hundreds
of countries around the world, and has an
active mechanism for, you know, freemium companies
to get paid as well as some of the other gateways.
But this, the both the getting paid and then
the management of the subscriptions is harder
than you might think, and again, you know,
without being paralysis to prevent you from
starting, you wanna put some time and thinking
into this early and there are some vendors
who are focused on that.
>>Dave:: And not missing the opportunity to
pimp a portfolio company, Recurly might be
a great option for you to check out, others
are Chargify, ah probably not Zuora unless
you want long contract fees and expensive
implementation.
>>Don: OK, last question.
>>Audience Male 7: Yeah you discussed briefly
about quota, about having a bus, having you
know your base package it's free, everyone
loves using it. But creating that quota of
well you can store 5 megabytes worth of documents
an hour, but you pay to get more space. In
your experience how is that, has that been
a viable business model? Paying for space,
coz as you said, bits are free. How likely
is a user in the end to pay to get more space
to store stuff? Does it just depend on what
the base product is?
>>Dave: So here's the other weird thing is
that Free is anything that you wouldn't take
the time to unsubscribe for. So actually I
think there are a lot of models that are free
really feels like less than $20 a month. I'd
be cautious about sort of annoying people
to like the end of their means, but, so Dropbox
is an example, there are a lots of other alternatives
for paying for stuff. I don't know why like
you know, certain people wanna pay $20 a month
for Dropbox other than the fact that $20 a
month to a lot of people doesn't feel like
a lot of money. So what you're really going
after there is, here's something useful and
here's something close to being free enough
that I don't care about it.
>>Brad: I think the key to having that dynamic
work though is that the product has to be
awesome. It has to delight. It has to be something
that doesn't cause you to go look for an alternative
that costs less than $20 a month. Because
you instinctively know they're out there but
you're so delighted with this product that
you're willing to keep paying for it. Right?
So, I think that's, that's part of the challenge.
It's interesting, there's a lot of free things
that could disintermediate for example your
cable TV system, and there, they just aren't
worth it yet, because they don't delight enough,
they're too hard. I don’t want my wife to
call me, like she did and say I can't get
this to work. And so I'm willing to pay something
until that point. You can scale that across
the whole thing. So just really focus on your
product on delighting in that context.
>>Jeff: Yeah and I think um, keeping in mind
that if you're in the enterprise you know,
if your bill owed $10, sort of mark you can
expense it using your credit card as personal
individual users you know, 3 bucks or 5 bucks
of month is just not that much money for a
delightful experience. So yes, in the case
of Dropbox if I need it I will pay for it.
And I won't wait until I'm sort of at the
threshold, I would just pay because I'm really
happy and I won't bother searching out something
else. And so I think its really the user experience
that you are driving for and then you figure
out what is the right hurdle that will sort
of get, you know this notion of demand curve
you will, you will try to find, where it's
optimal to get people to pay for X amount
at X capacity.
>>Audience Male 7: Okay. thank You.
>>Don: A reminder, if you're an entrepreneur
or a startup and you'd like to attend the
Google reception tonight, you need one of
these cards see David Crane over here, or
Joe Kraus or myself and we'll get you hooked
up. Thank you all for coming here and join
me in thanking my panel.
[Applause]